Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two. David, P.. Last week,
I said, I don't think it's a great idea for
Bernie to run again. I gave my reasons why.
As a Bernie supporter myself, in 2016 and
2020, 98 percent of the reactions from the
audience were substantive and respectful. Two
percent of the reactions were people calling me
all sorts of names because I thought, I think
Bernie's time has come and gone. He'd be
88 years old at the end of his
term. I don't think it makes sense.
But here's a question that I think is a good
one, which came up in response. Take a listen.
Speaker 2: Hey, David. Kyle, from Florida
here. Yes. I really like your take about Bernie
not running or running, potentially in
twenty twenty four. I was just curious. Who
would you like to see running, if not Bernie?
OK. That's the one thing I'm curious about is.
Those who could take up that mantle, so to speak.
Yeah, I do like could take there. I think that
you make a lot of good points.
Um, although we agree on a lot of
things here, you might not be the person anymore
Speaker 1: for the moment. All right. So listen,
this is a good question. Who, who? Who am I
interested in for 2024? I am not going to give you
some names right now. I am not telling you that
I agree with every one of these people's politics
more than I agree with Bernie's. I'm just giving
names of people that I think are interesting
and bring the energy I would like to see. These
are people of varying political orientations.
Some of them because of identity issues.
I don't know if they would really do well,
but here's just people I think are interesting
and are smart and bring good energy, and they're
not in any particular order. Congressman Jamie
Raskin, I think, is excellent. I think he's
brilliant. He actually is a progressive
activist. You look at his background and
he's a progressive activist. That's where he
comes from. He is very well-spoken and brings
some good energy. That's one person that
I think is interesting. Katie Porter, the
Democratic congresswoman I know a lot of people
say, David, does she have the experience or would
people vote for her? I'm just saying I really
like Katie Porter's energy, and I think she's
super smart, excellent in adversarial and debate
type situations. I think Katie Porter is a rising
star in the Democratic Party. Georgia Senator
Jon Ossoff, very young guy. I love his energy.
I think he's brilliant. I think he's a fantastic
speaker. Interesting guy. Pete Buda Judge Do I
love Pete's politics? Exactly. No, he's to my.
He's to my right. There's no question about that.
But he is so good when he goes on with adversarial
media. He's good at succinctly and pointedly
disarming, disarming, I guess we would say, and
delegitimizing right wing arguments. I would love
to see what he would do in a more prominent
position. And then I I think Stacey Abrams
is super interesting, and I think that she's
extremely smart and well-spoken as well,
like many of these other people. So those are
five Democrats that I think are interesting,
that bring more the energy that I want to see with
a range of different backgrounds and experiences
and identities. So those are just five ideas.
And I'm not saying they would win a primary.
They they all have reasons why we might say,
well, they're not like your typical fast track
Democratic primary candidate, but those are
five names I'm interested in. We have a great
bonus show for you today. The French people have
reelected their president Emmanuel Macron, and
that's good. But at the same time, it was much
closer, this time with Marine Le Pen, and we're
going to talk about that on the bonus show.
Senator former Senator Orrin Hatch, the longest
serving Republican senator, has passed away at
the age of 88. We will talk about his legacy.
And Twitter has banned ads that deny climate
change. Are people going nuts? Of course. Free
speech, First Amendment, et cetera. We will talk
about it all on today's bonus show. Sign up at
Join Packman dot com. You'll get instant access
to the bonus show. Lots of other great perks,
and you'll get the show every day. Six
hours before everybody else sign up at,
join Pacman dot com and we will see you
Unidentified: on the bottom.